facciamoci lo slam non aspettano seri
calcola che nessuno di snap mai tutto
eastern stories lancer fa niente
forest oil amo congratulazioni e ho
visto prima stare l'inter abbiamo ci
sono i filtri maio scena non chiuso 20
ma non mi piace per niente
cioè non ci sono i filtri ecco il bianco
e nero già un po più alla di più non può
concorrere un po noioso 6 sia tenacia il
clistere cioè come fai decidere cosa
pubblicare su una cosa pubblicare sul
lato ce la farò non sapessi non si può
vedere un arciere troppo avanti come
chiara ferragni fede cioè fare stessa
scena se su una certa su instagram
l'unica differenza che tu sei povera
dice di avere due o tre telefoni come
loro che sono scuri da sei cervello da
gallina la rappresenta proprio in pieno
ho visto che chiara ha pubblicato una
storia e aveva il più te linguaccia
quello che ti fa tibia ci sono i criteri
ho scoperto sondata la musica musica
stamati fonti disegnare minimo di tipo
perché da soli non lo scopro solo ora
allora perché se lo stato taglia sequel
poi non capisco perché avevo già tornate
chiti e le ragazze l'uso di nero che ha
patito non ho capito che spiega come non
è capito ma possibile che non vi
riguarda le mie storie
ma se l'inter mesi fa i vostri dimessa
florakis con le storie cioè sia docente
che se li si ricorda che non seguono voi
seguirete mio marito nestor osorio io
sapevo piacere ma l'ho sempre saputo che
la fai a vederla spari a ding in acqua
che mi fai screen dei cuori duro deve
che io vedo la sua storia che c'è
sicuramente chi sei tu dietro aspetta
fammi pensare c'è lotta alla cugina otto
anni al proprio privato già 45 di
prestazioni allora ecco perché piace
tanto instagram cioè si vola
[Musica]
davis thomas caterino polmoni è visto un
bacio perché no di mismetti misti milan
[Musica]
carattere